Київська міська клінічна лікарня №1.
Тут можуть одночасно приймати більше 600 пацієнтів.
Але бюджетного фінансування на всіх не вистачає.
Тож, як і в багатьох інших лікарнях України,
пацієнти змушені, за даними МОЗ,
купувати від 60 до 90%
необхідних для лікування препаратів і медзасобів.
Ми отримуємо пенсію в 1500 гривень.
За що можна жити? І ліки ще купувати? Які?
Не хочу я про це говорити…
В лікарні всім необхідним можуть забезпечити
тільки пільговиків. Та й те – деякі ліки
надає держава, а деякі - хворі змушені самі купувати.
Я тут ще відчуваю  хоча б частинку
безоплатної допомоги.
Але якби б це було для всіх,
то було б чудово.
Саме цього прагне досягти міністерство охорони здоров'я України
в рамках медичної реформи.
Передбачається, що вже з наступного року пацієнти
зможуть  отримати насправді безкоштовну
невідкладну допомогу. Доступнішими стане
і планове лікування. Хворі оплачуватимуть
лише частину вартості.
Це допоможе багатьом пацієнтам,
вважає хірург Сергій Онищенко. Адже зараз багато хто
може дозволити собі лише найдешевший
і часто неефективний варіант лікування.
Якщо реформа
буде працювати на 100% потужності, як це планується,
цей пацієнт буде мати страховий поліс,
отримає допомогу в медичному закладі,
за що медзаклад отримає кошти від страхової компанії.
Долучитися до фінансування планового лікування
зможе і держава. Але поки система співоплати -
пацієнт /держава/страхова компанія -
не розроблена. Немає і єдиних тарифів того,
скільки ж коштуватиме та чи інша допомога.
Та навіть якби розцінки і були, в лікарнях не впевнені,
що мають законні підстави брати гроші
зі страхових компаній.
Нам потрібно спочатку змінити законодавство, тому що
сучасне  законодавство і головний  документ -
це Конституція України, а саме 49-та стаття,
передбачає безкоштовне лікування.
Проте у МОЗ - інше трактування 49-ої статі.
Мовляв, навпаки, саме завдяки медреформі
Конституція нарешті почне виконуватися.
Це питання було врегульоване
завдяки розмежуванню понять
медична допомога та медична послуга. Адже компонент медичної допомоги
в тарифі послуги буде завжди оплачений
державою, як того і вимагає Конституція.
Як би там не було, а пацієнтів наразі більше цікавить
результат реформи.
Головне, звичайно, якість.
Але опять же ж якість. Якість буде залежати
від кармана і що в кармані лежить.
Уся Європа живе з медичним страхуванням.
А ми - як якесь
первісне  суспільство.
Багато лікарів у цій лікарні готові працювати по-новому.
Тим більше, що медреформа передбачає
і підвищення їх зарплатні. Проте весь пакет законопроектів
від міністерства охорони здоров"я досі Верховною Радою
не затверджений.